[Musique]
bonsoir imaginez une table et sur cette
table il ya cinq cent mille francs
alors pour les plus jeunes ça fait à peu
près 76 mille euros et de ses 500 mille
francs
moi je veux en gagner dix mille encore
une fois pour les plus jeunes
ça fait à peu près 1500 euros en une
soirée il ya vingt ans ça fait rêver
maintenant si je vous dis que à chaque
fois que je faisais ça je risquais
littéralement ma vie et quand je dis
littéralement s'est littéralement ça
fait un petit peu moins rêver non ou
alors vous êtes plutôt bizarre et ça ça
a été mon job pendant neuf ans
mon premier saut dans le milieu ça a été
à 18 ans alors j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à la triche et à tricher à
12 ans parce que ben je voulais pas que
ma soeur gagne au jeu à la bataille tout
simplement et je voulais pas que les
anciens mon père mon grand père arrive à
gagner et je pense que je voulais pas
que personne n'arrive à me battre tout
simplement
mais je suis rentré à 18 ans pour la
première fois dans un casino
j'ai joué j'ai triché j'ai gagné
beaucoup et bien sûr je me suis fait
prendre avec tout ce que ça comporte
derrière donc 18 ans c'est un petit peu
chaud on est majeur peut se passer plein
de choses et à ce moment là je me
retrouve dans le poste de sécurité avec
les agents de sécurité et on va me
proposer deux choix alors vous pourriez
me dire ça les risques du métier
mais allez comprendre un instant
pourquoi c'est intéressant on propose
donc deux choix
le premier choix c'est ben je rend
l'argent que j'ai gagné je suis
black-listé on prend en photo je peux
plus jouer en tout cas dans ce casino et
dans les danseuses du même groupe et on
me demande de rester jusqu'à la fin afin
de montrer aux croupiers ce que j'avais
fait parce que les croupiers avait pas
vu c'est la caméra qui m'a vu et moi à
l'époque je connaissais pas tout ce qui
était caméra et sécurité je demande
c'est paul deuxième choix et dans le
débat c'est la police donc je pense que
je réfléchisse un petit peu et je dis
bah je vais prendre le premier en fait
et donc je reste jusqu'à la fermeture
et je montre aux croupiers donc ce que
j'avais fait sous leurs yeux et c'est
intéressant par rapport à ce qu'il se
passera 27 ans après et je vois je vous
expliquais dans quelques instants
donc de cette expérience je prends ma
première claque je découvre le monde du
jeu entre guillemets première poussée
d'adrénaline
parce que j'ai la trouille mine de rien
j'ai 18 ans comme je vous disais je peux
aller en taule maintenant il n'y a plus
il ya plus la sécurité entre guillemets
et de cette expérience il va y avoir
deux événements majeurs qui vont se
présenter
le premier événement c'est que je me dis
la croupe ça me plaît alors la croupe
ces êtres croupier c'est le métier de la
croupe
le deuxième événement c'est que je
prends ma première rencontre la première
claque avec le thème de la soirée donc
et la résilience alors quand je dis
rencontre bien sûr c'est une image je
n'ai pas rencontré physiquement j'ai 18
ans à 18 ans on est plein d'impulsivité
on est plein de testostérone
je fais pas les forcément les bons choix
encore et donc je décide d'apprendre la
croupe d'apprendre le métier de croupier
pour être plus performant pour augmenter
mes connaissances pour mieux triché au
final vous ai dit mauvais choix et donc
j'arrive à rentrer dans un cercle de jeu
parisien
je fais la rencontre du patron je
m'explique ma volonté d'apprendre le
métier et il m'autorise à venir
m'entraîner entre guillemets à prendre
avec les croupiers résident avant
l'ouverture du cercle donc bah ça se
fait je suis super content j'apprends ça
me plaît et puis bon an mal an je
commence à prendre mes aises et je
commence à montrer deux trois petites
choses que je sais faire
qui sont pas normalement réglementaires
dans un cercle de jeu le patron mon
repère vois mes comptes mais mes
compétences pardon technique décide de
me virer du cercle de jeu alors que
j'étais même pas engager encore un et il
me rappellera quelques jours plus tard
pour venir jouer sur ces parties privées
alors quand je dis jouer vous avez
compris de quoi je parle alors mes
compétences à l'époque elles sont pas
énormes
c'est vraiment très technique je fais
essentiellement des fausses donne que ce
soit des essentiellement les donnes du
dessous mais aussi des douanes en second
des trucs et des mélanges que ce soit
des faux mélangent complet ou des
mélanges classificateurs qui permet de
poser les cartes dans certains endroits
des marquages de cartes à la volée pour
pouvoir voir qui accroît dans sa main et
je vous montrais il ya une petite vidéo
où je vous montre exactement là vous
allez voir ce qu'on appelle une donne en
seconde dont je voudrais parler et en
fait l'idée c'est de prendre la deuxième
carte et non pas la première du paquet
vous avez une vue exposé en gros plan et
là vous avez un mélange qui suis une
méthode plutôt classique dans les
casinos d'accord et qui a deux
particularités d'accord bien qu'il
paraisse complètement anodin la première
particularité c'est que les as vont
rester sur le dessus d'accord et en plus
de ça le jeu et à mélanger
donc vous voyez un petit peu donc avec
tout ça je commence à prendre contact
avec des magiciens parce que les
techniques se ressemblent même si c'est
pas exactement les mêmes et surtout avec
des tricheurs
j'arrive à rencontrer des tricheurs qui
m'explique un petit peu leur métier qui
m'explique un petit peu leur vie et du
coup ben le patron me fait travailler
sur ces parties privées donc je triche
pour lui je ne gagne pas directement
sauf quand je joue comme un joueur
en fait j'ai exactement de rôle pendant
cette partie soit je travaille comme
croupier soit je travaille comme joueur
la différence principale c'est au niveau
de la technique puisque vous vous
n'était bien qu'un joueur lambda je vais
jouer le rôle d'un joueur amateur ne
mélange pas ou ne distribue pas les
cartes de manière qu un croupier 107
fessionnels donc je joue pour lui je
gagne plutôt bien ma vie environ 10% du
pot en général le pot c'est la somme qui
va être allouée à la partie j'ai un
compte en banque
c'est le patron qui dirait mon compte
quand j'ai besoin de liquidités il me
les donne sans aucun problème et j'ai un
travail officielle à côté donc du coup
cet agent la sat argent là pardon je l'
épargne
je me dis on va préparer on va préparer
la suite et donc je vous ai dit ça a été
mon travail pendant neuf ans et 9 ans
plus tard je vais faire ma deuxième
rencontre encore une fois c'est une
image avec le thème qui est la
résilience je demande un rendez vous
avec le patron avec qui il avait des
liens géniaux et je lui dis ben voila je
veux arrêter je vais être papa et je
veux pas de cette vie pour mes enfants
et là d'un homme souriant agréable et
adorable avec moi je passe à un mur de
glace le regard change
et là je commence un petit peu avoir
peur et alors je sais pas pour quelle
raison à ce que j'ai eu de la chance
est ce que c'est parce qu'il met bien
bien il dit ok mais il ya deux
conditions la première je vais garder
l'argent que tu as gagné parce que c'est
mon dédommagement vu que tu me feras
plus gagné je gardais tout ça est la
deuxième condition c'est que tu te
fasses oublié je ne plus jamais entendre
parler de toi ni sur une table de jeu ni
dans un casino
j'ai des connaissances faut plus et là
dans ma tête ça fait tilt je pense que
j'ai dû sentir le moment où il fallait
que je prenne cette décision
pour vous donner une idée les journaux
appelleront ça plus tard la mafia corse
et donc du coup je reprends une vie
classique
je reprends une vie classique j'ai un
emploi ou une tout ce qui est classique
pardon et pour pas perdre la main
je me tourne vers l'illusionnisme en la
magie
classique est pareil discrètement je
fais quelques petites prestations dans
des bars sans faire de pub mais je fais
surtout beaucoup de créations pour
d'autres magiciens ce soit des magiciens
français où des magiciens internationaux
tout se passe bien jusqu'à ya à peu près
six ans il va se passer quelque chose
qui va me ramener à mes premiers amours
entre guillemets mais du bon côté de la
force
ça c'est pour les copains geek il ya six
ans donc une personne importante pour
moi mon papa fait un avc
je suis en région parisienne il est en
normandie et je réfléchis pas je promets
dispositions très rapidement et je
quitte tout et je pars et je pars et je
fais les 200 km je fais les 200 km et
j'arrive en normandie avec ma nouvelle
femme mes deux enfants
c'est ma fierté est sans emploi
j'arrive à trouver un logement mais sans
emploi mais avec les casinos tout autour
de moi vous imaginez
qui peut et dans mon petit serval ça
fait un deuxième tilt je me dis il ya 27
ans je monterais au croupier comment
j'avais pu arnaqué un petit peu la
maison le casino le cercle de jeu
pourquoi je le ferai pas nouveau mais de
manière officielle c'est là que je ne
triche plus mais je vais leur montrer
comment un tricheur peuvent venir faire
tomber la maison j'en discute avec ma
femme
d'abord je m'explique mon passé parce
que personne savait ce que j'avais fait
j'avais un boulot classique ça c'était
une autre vie mais vraiment une autre
vie personne savez mes parents ne
découvrent au fur et à mesure des
interviews et des conférences c'est pas
la première donc ils savent maintenant
et je commence à me remettre sur le
devant de la scène sans trop de crainte
parce que les personnes qui m'employait
sont au mieux en cavale au pire plus
parmi nous et vu ce que j'avais vu des
personnes que j'ai arnaquer il ya
personne qui portera plainte
j'en sais trop entre guillemets donc du
coup j'en parle à ma femme et je lui dit
écoute je triche plus je joue plus mais
pendant ce temps là j'ai augmenté mes
connaissances et mes connaissances
notamment sur les casinos
parce que la protection du jeu ce que je
fais maintenant dans les casinos
c'est pas juste savoir manipuler les
cartes comme vous avez pu voir sur la
vidéo énormément d'autres choses et la
technologie et le management
il ya la gestion du personnel il ya les
procédures de sécurité
les protocoles et tout ça je lui ai
appris alors je m'entraîne - mais j'ai
augmenté mes connaissances donc comme je
voulais dire par-là ma femme je lui
explique que ben voila j'ai envie de
faire ça il ya des petits
si j'ai 40 ans on repart à zéro et que
ça va pas être facile et l'a même dit
vas-y si c'est ce que tu veux faire
vas-y et je vais en profiter pour la
remercier la remerciera jamais assez
parce que c'est grâce à son soutien
merci de me supporter ce n'est pas
facile dans tous les sens du terme les
bons et les mauvais avoir quelqu'un qui
a des cartes en main toute la journée
c'est pas évident mais au final on dit
vas-y et grâce à elle aujourd'hui 27 ans
plus tard j'ai une auto entreprise dans
protection du jeu je travaille avec les
casinos avec les cercles de jeu ce soit
en france ou ailleurs
tu es de la formation professionnelle
pour eux avec cette auto entreprise à
côté pardon je vois aussi des
démonstrations de triche
je fais des conférences entre autres
pour les magiciens mais aussi pour les
entreprises
parce qu'on se rend compte rapidement
que la psychologie d'un tricheur peut
être appliquée à la gestion d'une
entreprise ou à la gestion de la
concurrence et à côté de ça en plus je
fais de la surveillance de partie privée
est un petit peu toujours
d'illusionnisme et de magie parce que ça
m'amuse
tout ça pour dire que quand on y
réfléchit bien la résilience ce principe
de résilience c'est quelque chose de
très personnel
y a que vous qui puissiez le faire mais
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut le faire
tout seul
moi j'ai eu cette chance c'est d'avoir
du monde autour de moi qui m'a aidé ma
famille mes amis ma femme à me pousser
et à faire les bons choix pardon c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut pas faire tout
seul j'avais un maître d'arts martiaux
puis j'ai pratiqué depuis mon enfance
aussi qu'ils disaient les échecs c'est
ce qui construit une belle vie ouais je
suis pas super sur 200 par contre ce
dont je suis sûr c'est que si vous
arrivez à surmonter le trauma parce que
ça s'appelle comme ça je dis pas
l'accepter j'ai pas l'oublier j'ai à le
surmonter à le comprendre
al passer outre et essayer d'avancer à
ce moment là vous pourrez réussir tout
ce que vous voulez dans votre vie
et je voudrais juste terminée sur une
phrase que j'aime particulièrement d'un
grand philosophe qui s'appelle requis
balboa auriez pas et cette phrase c'est
peu importe le nombre de fois où la vie
va te mettre ko le plus important c'est
de relever lever la tête faire front et
avancer je vous remercie beaucoup de
m'avoir écouté et puis je vous souhaite
une excellente fin de soirée merci à
vous
[Musique]